what I'm doing today charlie is I'm
making this video as a kind of time
capsule for you or for myself I guess
the idea being that I'm going to make
this video today I've learned into
YouTube and then not watch it until my
30th birthday so when I say Charlie I am
in fact directing myself to myself but
10 years in the future - 30 year-old
Charlie how I'm 30 year old Charlie how
you doing now firstly I know what you're
thinking because I am you you're
thinking oh my God look at his hair I
realize that I need a haircut I realized
that I look like a bit of an idiot I'm
sure you've grown up now and you've
trimmed yourself into something
respectable but no I'm proud of being a
little bit weird and that's just the way
I was and the second thing charlie is
that um I hope you're not dead
bit morbid I know but I couldn't really
help thinking about it just kind of
imagining myself as a 30 year old led me
on to kind of think I'm gonna be fifty
one day I'm gonna be seventy one day oh
I'm gonna be dead one day so yeah I hope
you're not dead I'm just gonna assume
for the purposes of this video that
you're not dead and move on so this is
how I am currently or this is how I was
ten years ago to you I'm here now in
what to me is a brand new bedroom just
moved into this flat in London like
about three weeks ago I just finished
building this which is the wall of stuff
2.0 I'll show you around my bedroom a
little bit as well let me just grab you
this is my desk
got some toys there yes I still keep
toys I wonder if I'll still keep toys on
my desk when I'm thirty I hope so that's
my Fez hiding up there in the corner and
remember that as well as having your own
room you also had your own ensuite
bathroom look at that pretty sweet
something almost as cool as having your
own ensuite bathroom was you had your
own flatmate remember that there is high
it's your flatmate no I'm not dead or
anything have you really oh good I was
just talking about that before really er
do you think that we will still be
friends in ten years time yeah yeah
definitely like I didn't even really
question that it's in death would be
there anything together yeah yeah yeah
definitely
oh that's why things like that so that's
that thing your room mate thanks a lot
that's alright I'm still single
currently which I'm sure you remember
very well I wish this could be more of a
two-way conversation because I would
really like to know
you have a wife or not is she hot as
well I bet she's hot I mean obviously
more importantly she better be witty and
funny and creative and joy to spend time
with but you know she better be caught
as well I hope she's hot it's possible
you'll even have kids which is a weird
actually no you won't have kids by the
time you're 30 no offense
I'd really love to know what you're
doing as well because at the moment this
video blogging thing this is what was or
maybe still is your job I would hope at
least that you're still doing the
YouTube thing in in some way or another
because it's fun you know I know it's
fun you know it's fun you know I can
wonder all I want about my future but
then at the end of the day I think it's
more important just to kind of focus on
where you are and where I am right now
in this kind of little time bubble type
thing I'm happy and I'm in a good place
you had food to eat you had friends that
you liked you had a job that you liked
and you know that was enough so I hope
that whatever situation you find
yourself in now thirty-year-old Charlie
you still have the simple things and um
yeah that's all I had to say really just
to kind of wrap things up you might
remember John Green I hope you still in
contact with John John is an actual 30
year old and I asked him to give some
advice to a 30 year old Charlie and this
is what we came up with John Green
everybody the good news is that you are
still just getting started you're gonna
watch this when you're 30 you're gonna
think to yourself oh my god how these
last 10 years have passed and look how
old I look and everything else but
really you're still in the first half of
the game statistically that's I like to
say yeah that was John Green see you in
ten years charlie bye you've just had
the almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool